I'm Kevin, I'm a friend and
programmer here at Udacity.
The most exciting thing about
front end programming for
me is creating a pleasing and
intuitive user experiences.
The most difficult challenge that I face
as a front end programmer is meeting
the requirements of a project as
well as satisfying my own desire to
have elegant code.
You're always trying to meet a deadline.
That's a constant struggle of
how perfect can I get this and
still deliver on time.
The approach I try to take is to really
understand what your product manager or
consumer want and iron out the most
basic functionality first,
get it to a point where they can look at
it, critique it and give you feedback.
In the remaining time you have, that's
where you get to the interesting and
fun work of polishing the experience.
Front end is a pretty diverse field.
Even when I find myself
with a heavy workload,
I find it very easy to stay motivated
and stay engaged in the work that I do
because I believe that it does
have a really positive impact.
So to me that's kind of a sign that
this is the right path for me.